>> We visualize quartiles and outliers with box plots also called box and whisker
plots. It looks like this, where this line represents the min. This line
repressents the locatin of Q1. This line represents of Q2 or the median. This
line repsresents the locatin of Q3. And this line is the max, and then, outliers
are represented by dots in their respective location. Boxplots can also be drawn
sideways like this, with the minimum value, the median, Q1 and Q3, and then the
maximum value, with dots that represent the outliers. Given that information,
which of these boxplots do you think corresponds to these distributions? This
one with and without Mark Zuckerberg, and this general population distribution.
And just a hint, this dot right here is an outlier. So, type A, B, or C into
each of these red boxes, corresponding to these boxplots.